so many people describe it as if not the  perfect show the near-perfect show any  regrets is there anything that you do  differently if you go back in time and  do anything differently on the show  obviously there is it has to do this  gentleman right here yeah show them the  film show me teeth and that the priest  set of choppers you've ever seen yeah  and and this guy you got your ass kicked  so much yeah like every like you know  like three times an episode for 62  episodes plus you're smoking a lot of  Mathis man and he's a man he's a meth  addict can't you go back digitally and I  would pay for it and spur up his teeth  in every episode I would know it don't  you want to see that I will make sure  that you look like [ __ ] I'll do that for  the money  I got it  you